Germany's president Frank Welter
steinmeier has described Russia's
invasion of Ukraine as a turning point
in history his comments came in a rare
nationally televised speech he said the
world was entering a period of
Confrontation and called on people to
face the future with strength turned
many people in the country would have to
make sacrifices and call for a change in
mentality
I said acknowledging a new reality was
the only way people would be able to
meet the challenges that lie ahead
and not even a German president can take
away all our worries in these profoundly
uncertain times
I believe that many of these words are
legitimate we are experiencing the
deepest crisis our United Germany has
ever known
but I'm firmly convinced that if we
become consciously aware of this moment
this turning point in history if we
begin to understand that one era has
come to an end and another has begun
and only then will we be able to see
more clearly what is now required of us
that we will not have to face this new
era in fear
or without defense
let's join the idw's uh Emmanuel Shaz
who's at the presidents at Bellevue
Palace so welcome Emmanuel
um this was quite a somber speech wasn't
it
it was a quite a somber speech a stand a
warning that Society was changing and
also that there was no uh coming back to
how things were before there were there
were three main points in uh
speech of course what really dominated
it was Russia's war of aggression
against Ukraine the president German
president
has been very very moved by his visits
in Ukraine on October 2050 really talked
at length about this experience and
about what people on the ground in
Ukraine were going through at the time
another uh point that was a really
dominant in that speech was the state of
things here in Germany Germany is going
through difficult times as well of
course there's no comparison with what
ukrainians are going through that's also
something that the president highlighted
in his speech but he did mention the
economy economic crisis he did mention
the necessity for Germany to become
independent from a Russian energy and
also he mentioned and that was his third
major point he did mention climate
change saying that we simply couldn't
afford to wait to tackle it to address
it and to take measures for to try and
contain it the German presidency is
largely ceremonial why has he decided to
to make this this nationally televised
speech on these four themes Ukraine the
economy Russian energy and climate
change why is the president speaking out
like this
I think you know this was a much awaited
speech thank you had made himself
relatively scared this year and many
were calling for him to speak up to uh
to address the nation is especially in
light of Russia's war against uh Ukraine
because you know the president here in
Germany is a moral Authority and in that
regard he is expected to take a stand
especially when it comes to moments of
historical change the way we are
witnessing since February he had already
given a speech back in May uh on on the
8th of May the day of liberation of
Europe and just as he had done back then
he also you know used very very strong
words when he talked about President
Russian President Vladimir Putin he did
call him as a leader he named him the
leader of an army of innovation he also
said that Putin was was trying to divide
Germany to divide a Europe Society he
even said that Putin was using division
as a poison to infiltrate
European society and for that a very
reason people in Europe have to unite
thank you Father Emmanuel dwc Manuel
Shaz at the presidential Palace in
Berlin